hello if you are here to join our little
lesson about the recent advances in the
natural language processing or short NLP
field you are exactly at the right place
we will follow the young but explosive
life of the transformer architecture
that revolutionized the AI field of NLP
it all started a few years ago where the
fun in AI was happening in computer
vision with the great success of CNN's
on the imagenet challenge I am talking
about you Alex net in 2013 the success
of neural style transfer end of
generative address our networks and the
list can go on and on computer vision
was attracting headlines and NLP was not
so much in the public's attention of
course NLP researchers were working hard
to for example 2013 was the year of word
to wake based on the idea that neural
networks should be forced to learn
similarities between words based on word
distributions for example the word Apple
is often used near the same words as
Microsoft or IBM so it is mapped close
to these in the vector space but Apple
is also used often with words like pear
or other fruits so we see that we cannot
disambiguate words contextually with
this method 2014 and 2015 were marked by
the rising popularity of the recurrent
neural network that made it feasible to
not only solve classification tasks
better but also tasks for a sequence to
sequence modeling an example for
generating a sequence from a sequence is
machine translation the idea of
recurrent neural networks or RN ends is
simply put the following the same neural
network block is applied recurrently on
the input sequence reaching the sequence
end the module ideally has learned one
single vector that captures the meaning
of the whole sentence and from the
single vector one can start to translate
by reverting the process in the
decoder but one problem of the method is
it works well for short sentences like I
am working hard that can be perhaps
captured by a single vector but not for
sentences like the second one there are
an end block reaching the end of the
sequence is so overwhelmed by the input
that it forgets what the beginning of
the sentence was 2015-2016 where the
years that took care of this forgetting
problem by employing the attention
mechanism this attention is nothing more
than a way to say which part of the
sentence should get more importance in
other words attention tells the errand
and what it should focus on and not
forget yet another problem with
recurrent neural networks is that they
are recurrent unfortunately sentences
are processed sequentially word by word
like generally humans do for a machine
this means however that it needs a lot
of time to process huge corpora of text
and here it is where 2017 BAM the
finally long-awaited imagenet moment
came also for NLP with the transformer
architecture it first crashed the party
with the attention is all you need paper
like the title already says if RN ends
and the tension are so slow because of
the sequential processing of our and
ends let us just use only attention and
throw away they are NN part and boom
here it was the transformer in practice
this is a little more complicated than
this and we will explain the transformer
architecture in the next video here we
put it very simply transformers like RN
ends handle sequence data but not in a
particular order this means that it can
train much faster with parallelization
now focusing less on how it works we
focus what a transformer means and what
came out of the original transformer
because this architecture and it's
descendants proved to be improving the
state of the art across the board like
in machine translation sentiment
classification core reference resolution
common-sense reasoning and so on and so
on it has been
also successfully applied on translating
from one programming language to another
or for solving symbolic mathematics and
if you want to see the transformer in
action do not hesitate to play around
with demos like the one here coming back
to our history lesson 2018 Google
researchers developed a bi-directional
version of the transformer and they
called it Bert yes you heard right
worked from Sesame Street now let's not
get distracted by the weird names
researchers choose for their model and
let us focus on the word bi-directional
regarding the transformer bi-directional
means that it allows the information to
flow forwards and backwards as the model
trains which results in better model
performance versions of Bert are one of
the most successful advances in NLP like
were Tuvok Bert is also mapping similar
words closely but it is
context-sensitive this means that a
different word vector is computing for a
word if it is encountered in different
contexts
for example if we have two sentences
like this game is just not fair and I
had a great time at this fair the word
fair will have very different word
vectors with Bert but equal valued word
vectors will be computed by word Tuvok
and after birth everything just
escalated for attention based
architectures in 2019 researchers
developed roberta early 2.0 excel net
and this to only name a very small
fraction all improve upon birth both
conceptionally and in performance but
these architectures just keep coming
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel yet and now to make it even
crazier we close the circle by going
back to the computer vision community
because the transformer is also making
waves there the transformer proved to be
so performant on text sequences that it
was also applied to pixel sequences or
us we usually call them images and wait
there is even more if we can apply
transformers on
or images why not apply them on text and
images simultaneously here we are in the
so-called realm of multi modality where
the goal is to process different input
sources at once so still 2019 was the
year of the elbert visual bird the eye
of bird unit air and this is just name a
few all these papers came out around the
same month of August 2009 teen 3 of them
on the same day what a time to be an NLP
researcher hard to be not both
overwhelmed and overly excited at the
same time to finally end this crazy
enumeration the transformer works so
well on multiple tasks and in many cases
even though it was not explicitly
trained on the task of interest so we
are now at a point in NLP where we have
to investigate if a neural network
trained on task a is also able to more
or less solve a task B for more
information on how to probe for this
check out our previous video linked here
in the video and in the description
below if you want to know more about the
inner workings of the transformer wait
until our next video thanks for watching
do not forget to Like and subscribe and
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]